bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission
au collège sainte-thérèse les élèves de
la classe de 4e à projets prépare
l'adaptation de l'oeuvre mythique de
bram stocker dracula un projet théâtral
au coeur de leur apprentissage toutes
les précisions avec nos invités dans
quelques instants dans le cadre de
rencontres lectures l'auteure isabelle
pandazopoulos s'est rendu au lycée de la
plaine 2 nov la trappe pour son roman la
décision le prisme à elancourt donne
carte blanche à kader attou l'une des
figures marquantes de la danse hip hop
et que la gervais l'a rencontré pour
connaître sa sélection alors joué au
théâtre en classe de 4e n'a rien
d'exceptionnel comme ça en soi mais
lorsque le projet théâtre s'articule
autour d'un objectif commun
pluridisciplinaire qui permet aux jeunes
de s'exprimer différemment que par des
résultats scolaires
les apprentissages prennent alors tout
leur sens pour ces élèves de la classe
de quatrième un projet au collège
sainte-thérèse au mesnil saint denis et
nous à parlons ce soir avec leur
professeur de français
christine ne rouvrant ce parc besoins et
vous êtes venu accompagné d'une des
élèves donc alice pardon excuses moins
fou fou à chaque parent donc pas là mais
tu es en dans cette classe de 4e à
projets alors peut-être avant qu'on
parle de la représentation que vous
allez donner vendredi
donc ce vendredi le 14 mars au théâtre
est de l'institut marcel rivière dans
une gêne car la verrière crise inhérents
à ce que pouvaient déjà nous re préciser
nous rappeler les grandes lignes
fondatrices de cette classe quatrième à
projet qu'est ce que c'est et ça
s'adresse à quel élève alors cette
classe à projet théâtral regroupe
dix-sept élèves qui étaient en
difficulté scolaire pour des raisons de
rythm is it est trop importante et il
n'arrive pas à suivre pour des raison de
lacunes cognitives qu'il fallait leur
redonner et ses enfants sont rentrés
dans cette classe sur lettre de
motivation c'est à dire qu'on a forcé
personne ce sont les élève qui écrivent
une lettre pour postuler à cette classe
le but de cette classe est bien
évidemment et toute l'équipe est
complètement comment dire en
interdisciplinarité transit narith
essaie de redonner confiance en leurs
justement redonnant des bases les
lacunes et des bases fondamentales des
savoirs mais aussi redonner confiance à
travers un projet ambitieux que d'un
projet de création et qui était un
projet théâtral donc en fait l'oeuvre
théâtrale est au centre et des étrangers
et ensuite toutes les disciplines vont
être fédérer autour de ce projet alors
le projet littéraire peut-être d'abord
première question à toi lise qu'est-ce
qui table justement ton professeur
disait tu as écrit une lettre de
motivation tu as même passé un entretien
avec le chef d'établissement pour
intégrer cette classe qu'est ce qui t'a
motivé pourquoi tu voulais voulait aller
dans la classe quatrième à projets bah
je voulais y aller parce que le théâtre
m'intéressait beaucoup qui me vient
enfin en dehors et aussi pour pouvoir
par exemple ne gérer mes émotions ou
plus pouvoir m'améliorer dans des
matières comme par exemple france est
d'accord donc tu es tu arrivé dans cette
classe en te disant voilà moi j'ai des
objectifs je veux y répondre en fin
d'année oui et aujourd'hui est ce que tu
peux déjà nous dire voilà cette classe
m'a permis d'arriver à tel ou tel
finalité est ce que tu en es contente
oui j'en suis content j'ai même réussi à
faire tout ce que je voulais faire
d'accord donc les objectifs sont remplis
oui donc christine voilà ça c'est une
d'un des objectifs fondamentaux pour
vous qui gagne confiance on ne vous
parliez du rythme scolaire n'était pas
facile
dans la classe lambda ou dans des
classes ordinaires là effectivement ils
sont exactement le même nombre d'heures
de cours avec simplement un supplément
qui n'est pas négligeable ont d'abord
une attention particulière puisqu'ils ne
sont que 10 c'est donc une attention
toute particulière de des collègues mais
aussi des heures d'accompagnement
éducatif où il travaille pendant trois
heures sur place au collège dans leur
emploi du temps pour leur donner des
méthodes de travail et pour leur
permettre d'apprendre à apprendre voilà
et d'être efficace parce que ces
enfants-là bien souvent quand ils se
retrouvent chez eux ont beaucoup de mal
à gérer un agenda et puis la
méthodologie havre on en parle beaucoup
de la méthodologie mais surtout
apprendre à apprendre ils veulent bien
faire mais malheureusement bien souvent
ils ont des problème de mémorisation
liés essentiellement à des problèmes de
concentration et de motivation tout
simplement ont fait la preuve avec des
scénarios le scénario théâtrale qui est
adapté de l'oeuvre alors vous en parlez
va s'emballer voilà importante cette
oeuvre yvette année voilà vous avez
choisi de travailler sur l'oeuvre
mythique de bram stocker rats kullas
dracula pourquoi pourquoi ce thème mais
ça surprend tout le monde pourtant tout
le monde connaît et dracula j'ai presque
envie de dire tout on connaît dracula et
personne ne connaît l'oeuvre de bram
stocker et ça nous semblait c'est une
oeuvre qui est inscrite au programme de
cap de la classe de 4e fait partie de la
littérature fantastique mais nous sommes
s'emparer de cette oeuvre parce que nous
estimions que est d'abord elle fait écho
auprès des jeunes quand on a proposé de
reculer à la classe ils étaient tous
très très content il a peut-être pas les
mêmes références mais voilà il a fallu
creuser
creusez l'oeuvre pour leur montrer que
eux-mêmes étaient quelque part
sujet ou soumis à vampirisation on a
essayé on a donné une interprétation
très particulière et très personnel avec
guillaume de mort à une interprétation
ou en fait ces jeunes sont très soumis
sont très vamp irisé par leurs écrans
sont parfois aussi à cet âge là très
vampirisé par des copains et donc il me
semblait intéressant de leur montrer que
dans cette oeuvre là nous tous nous
avons montré que l'omb la part d'ombré
de lumière où chacun de nous existent
comportent tous un dracula en soi et
c'est une heure aussi très structurante
du point de vue des valeurs parce que
c'est une valeur face d'un livre qui
oppose le bien et le mal et c'est donc
grâce à des limites voilà et c'est grâce
à une équipe de personnages que et on me
now que joël ou alice mène au triple
galop que justement on va éradiquer ce
mal grâce à la science mais aussi grâce
à des valeurs du bien alors juste à vous
comment comment vous avez abordé ces
thèmes de quelle manière vous les avez
traité puisque là vous vous donner une
vision on n'est pas dans les vampires
qui mordent qui transmettent mais c'est
enfin y'a pas une notion de sens non
voilà même le personnage même du vampire
n'apparaît pas non alors comment vous
l'avez traité du coup bien on voulait
effectivement ne pas tomber dans toute
cette filmographie ou représentation du
vampire bon sanguinaire ou du vampire
gentil comme les twilight puisque ça
fait le délice de nos de nos collégiens
on voulait montrer justement que
la le vampire c'est un cetain c'est un
personnage qui incarne le mal et que eux
mêmes il y avait des douleurs à être
comment dire soumis des désirs à des
choses qui attire mais en même temps
font mal et donc on l'a traité de point
de vue la représentation guillaume de
morat a fait le choix de traiter toutes
les parties je dirais attractive et
spectaculaires dont certains cinéastes
sent pas en ombres chinoises
et d'ailleurs c'est grâce à l'idée de
certains collègues notamment sciences
physiques eux en arts plastiques que
tout ce travail d'ombré de lumière a été
travaillé en classe alors pour donner
quelques examens voilà ce que c'est ça
qui est intéressant le en plus oui
j'irai de l'oeuvre c'est que le projet
fédère toutes les autres disciplines
j'aimerais que vous me donnez des
exemples voilà oui grec comment je sais
pas - les mathématiques les sciences
l'art plastique voilà a pu intégrer le
projet dracula bien pour me sarr est en
ligne la russe avec c'est à dire que
nous avons rendu toute la matière qui va
nourrir le travail du metteur en scène
donc le professeur de sciences physiques
s'est emparé évidemment d'un thème
évident dans dracula c'est-à-dire
l'ombre et la lumière et puis le
professeur de mathématique puisque vous
savez qu'il ya beaucoup de caisses avec
les cercueils parce que dracula arrive
avec tous ces cercueils en angleterre il
a travaillé les volumes il a travaillé
aussi la démarche scientifique puisque
c'est un professeur le professeur van
helsing qui va justement persuader tous
les personnages que le vampire va
peut-être vaincu et qu'il incarne un
certain nombre de choses bon et puis le
professeur d'arts plastiques va
travailler sur les représentations il a
fait travailler sur des arrangements sur
des photos qu'ils ont prises et puis
ensuite des photos de plus en plus
agrandi et enfin pour donner à faire
avec des systèmes de photoshop pour
essayer de rectifier l'image donc il y
aura un diaporama aussi qui passera
pendant le spectacle le professeur de
psa travailler aussi sur équilibre et
déséquilibre puisque c'est des
personnages qui sont équilibrées mais
qui à un moment donné
du fait de la vampirisation sont
déséquilibrés bref tout à tout le monde
c'est un geste le professeur d'anglais a
fait jouer une scène en anglais donc il
ya une toute une peine qui a été
traduite moi je vous propose c'est qu'on
écoute aussi le metteur en scène est ce
vous en parlait beaucoup alors on va
l'écouter c'est guillaume de moura qui
justement nous explique qu'on a
rencontrée ce matin cours des
répétitions en quoi c'est un véritable
projet de création qui requiert une
application de chacun
je suis pas simplement ici pour faire un
atelier qui voit là puis c'est tout et
puis se passe autre chose après une fois
que je suis parti là il ya un vrai une
vraie notion de projet où tout le monde
soit les enfants tous les adultes moi on
est vraiment dans une logique de tout le
monde vont créer un projet est donc là
dedans on réfléchit tous à la création
des décors à la création des costumes et
on essaie d'associer et les adultes et
les enfants à la au projet de création
et finalement tout le monde apprend dans
ce projet et puis ça permet aussi de
montrer aux ados
le fait qu'un adulte c'est pas un entité
qui est quelque part et puis ils sont
albert et temps en temps faire des
choses ensemble et ça peut être
intéressant et ça peut être les ans et
voilà même c
on a eu quelques fous rires à voile à
travailler ensemble et à montre la
d'ultimes entre aussi temps en temps ses
faiblesses genre quand il faut dessiner
un truc et patrick catastrophe et que
l'enfant il se rend compte que lui
dessine mieux et ça aussi ça fait partie
du processus de dire à l'enfant voilà ce
n'est pas quelque chose apparaît et tu
peux avoir une conversation avec un
adulte et tu peux être grand et tu peux
être fort et tu peux être fier de toi en
finale parce que c'est ça l'objectif
alors voilà l'objectif et ce sont les
maîtres mots de la classe quatrième à
projets est fier de soi se sentir
capable redonner du sens en fait à tous
ces apprentissages toualy ce qu'est ce
que ça t'a apporté le théâtre basse ma
porte est justement de la flore de la
confiance en soi sam a perdu le sens
vraiment plus forte aujourd'hui prennent
la forte est ce que tu as envie de parce
qu'à terme l'idée c'est de ces que tu
intègres ou
une troisième général ou une troisième
avec un projet professionnel est ce que
aujourd'hui c'est a déjà des idées de ce
que tu veux faire oui c'est déjà quelque
peu d'aidé lesquels bas par exemple
passé déjà en 3e générale et puis
peut-être faire souffleur de verre ou
travailler dans le plexus d'accord ans
passés très près si effectivement mais
en tout cas merci beaucoup à tout les
deux d'être revenue sur notre plateau on
rappelle donc la représentation de ces
vendredis 14 mars à 20h au théâtre de
l'institut marcel rivière donc il faut
pas hésiter oui vous allez porter votre
public c'est un théâtre public le tout
les barrières seront ouvertes à
l'accueil à un petit numéro de téléphone
me pour réserver n'hésitez pas merci
beaucoup à tous les deux alors nous
maintenant on va partir du côté du lycée
et c'est celui du lycée de la plaine de
neuf donc à trappes où s'est déroulée
une rencontre lecture avec l'auteure
isabelle pandazopoulos pardon pour son
roman la décision un thème pas toujours
abordé dans la littérature jeunesse
puisqu'il s'agit il s'agit du déni de
grossesse chez une adolescente des
images de jonathan vilma 7 au cdi du
lycée de la plaine de neauphle attrape
que se sont rencontré des élèves de
seconde et l'auteure isabelle
pandazopoulos son roman intitulé la
décision a été choisi par une vingtaine
d'élèves pour participer au défi lecture
proposée par les enseignants les élèves
et bien ont tout de suite été accroché
par le thème par le fait qu'une lycéenne
un couche dans les toilettes du lycée je
pense que le thème le cadre
les a interpellés tout de suite et c'est
l'un des livres qui a eu plus de succès
un succès couronné par une rencontre
avec l'auteur une occasion d'échanger
notamment sur la méthode d'écriture le
rôle des personnages et le sujet de fond
le déni de grossesse chez une
adolescente un sujet rarement abordé
dans la littérature jeunesse c'est
absolument pas intérêt c'est un roman
donc je me suis documenté effectivement
pour être en plus juste des sentiments
du personnage principal et la réalité
que je décrivais mais tout est inventé
c'est un bout en tous les cas c'est
extrêmement caricaturée dans les dans la
presse puisque c'est on en parle des
dénis de grossesse quand y'a des
infanticides ou quand il ya des procès
par contre la logique et dans ce dans
quoi le personnage les femmes sont quant
à elles vivent ça c'est absolument pas
pris en compte ou raconter où on n'est
que dans le spectaculaire
l'idée c'était de d'essayer de
comprendre parce que c'est extrêmement
mystérieux on pense que ça arrive à
personne que mais en fait c'est quelque
chose qui qu'il a qui est autour de nous
mais personne n'en parle alors ça m'a
intéressé quand j'ai vu que je me suis
dit j'ai envie d'en savoir plus moi j'ai
pas de point de vue sur ce que le
lecteur peut retenir injustement l'idée
c'était plutôt de le faire réfléchir et
d'être émue
par le parcours de cette jeune fille et
du coup d'essayer de
d'adopter un point de vue critique
plutôt que d'être dans des pensées
stéréotypé qu'on croque tout seul c'est
pas facile n'a pu savoir ce qu'elle
ressentait sur le livre et tout ça et
comment elle l'a écrit dans quelles
conditions à quoi la pensée quand elle
l'a écrit s'enrichissant de savoir
comment la fait tous les ans des
rencontres lectures sont organisées par
le réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines isabelle
pandazopoulos rencontrera collégiens et
lycéens du territoire jusqu'au 21 mars
alors comme vous le savez cette année
nous fêtons 30 ans de hip hop sur le
territoire et à cette occasion le prisme
à hello cour donne carte blanche à l'une
des figures de la danse hip hop kader
attou qui est également directeur du
centre chorégraphique national de la
rochelle nicolas gervais l'a rencontré
pour les côtes
figure majeure de la danse le hip hop il
dirige actuellement le centre
chorégraphique de la rochelle et le
prisme lui accorder une carte blanche à
l'occasion de 30 ans de hip hop à saint
quentin en yvelines il dut présente donc
the roots son spectacle mais également
aux reds d'anthony egéa le 14 mars et le
16 mars c'est anne nguyen avec promenade
obligatoire voici donc kader attou dans
le kiosque saut de l'ange
niko non
samyn m'a contacté c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu ma maison ici je suis venu
à plusieurs reprises montré mon travail
etc ans habite m'a proposé ont fait de
cette carte blanche j'ai tout
naturellement accepté de chorégraphes
issus de l'esthétique hip hop avec une
parité certaines anthony egea et avec
son spectacle rage et alain nguyen avec
promenade est obligatoire
soit 0 207 j'ai eu une sorte de
rétrospective personnel sur mes 20 ans
passés sur scène je me suis posé la
question mais tout ça ça vient d'où
finalement quoi et je me suis revue mois
grâce que j'étais en 84 j'avais 10 ans
je découvrais a chipé à choper
je me suis posé la question mais s'il
n'avait pas eu cette émission parce que
je serai là en train de vous parler ou
en train de danser tout simplement quoi
je me suis entouré de onze danseurs hip
hop d'excellence le point
d'interrogation d'euros c'est finalement
qu'est-ce que c'est la danse hip hop
donc j'ai fait tout un travail à partir
de ce que sont les danseurs de leur
histoire etc c'est pas un spectacle qui
narre l'histoire la danse hip hop mais
c'est plus un spectacle danse on
pourrait qualifier ça d'un ballet où je
mets en fait en
en facettes toutes là
la richesse de cette danse cette danse à
la fois dans son énergie dans son
esthétique dans sa prouesse technique
dans sa poésie
et
a montré qu'à danse hip hop n'est pas
qu'une danse de la prouesse et de
l'énergie mais elle peut être autre
chose faite et là on s'inscrivent à
manquer dans un bidon usant du hip hop
comment dire à 100% si je pourrais dire
et c'est une pièce qui bouleverse parce
que l amène le spectateur en fait là où
il déjà mais ils auront imaginer un jour
il ya
voyager en fait avec cette danse je
pense
le crem s'est on va dire les variantes
de la danse hip hop entre parenthèses
dans ce n'est de los angeles qui a comme
en dira pour
gestuelle une manière de ressortir tout
lavage le mal être là la haine qu'on
peut avoir en tout cas sur un certain
nombre de choses et quand l'on ressort
un peu de cette manière donc ça criait
en tout cas un style assez atypique donc
une manière de sortir de 32 thorn et ses
ailes pour la jeter
ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la danse hip
hop le hip hop à une émotion mondiale
c'est à dire que à caracas à calcutta en
afrique ou ailleurs vous trouverez ces
danseurs et pour ça c'est certain
on se nourrit forcément de là où on
vient en fait notre hip hop en france et
nori de la danse contemporaine par
exemple et d'autres choses en afrique
elle sait pas nourri de la danse
contemporaine elle se nourrit forcément
d'autres choses et de leur histoire à
ses danseurs la cua et donc ça a donné
quelque chose assez extraordinaire en
tout cas et dans la façon de vivre et
dans la façon de l'ide ans et anthony en
tout cas avec ses danseurs il est il est
parti explorer
toute cette rage kalkan de craintes la
version afrique et ça c'est un cocktail
assez étonnant
on parle de coping on parle de femmes on
parle d'homme aussi contrairement à la
quasi-totalité de faire de moi même il
ya des hommes anin cannes en tout cas la
féminité et la danse au féminin en hip
hop et les dents provenant obligatoire
ne serait-ce que la proposition
elle même est intéressante c'est une
chorégraphie en discontinu comme ça de
part et d'autre c'est à dire de de cour
à jardin sans qu'il y ait un moment
donné les sans arrêt c'est à dire que
les danseurs traversent le plateau
pendant une heure sur une chorégraphie
très élaboré
il ya quelque chose de très hypnotique
en fait dans ce travail là et c'est vrai
que tout les aspects esthétiques entre
autres le popping le smurf le boogaloo
aussi des doors debout hip hop il y
largement représentés quoi et donc du
coup ça fait ça fait pour moi une sorte
de de contrepoids avec la proposition
d'anthony et celle de manon
et une info d'importance encore avant de
nous quitter sachez que pour une place
achetée poweredge c'est une place
offerte pour promenades obligatoires le
cese alors de spectacles pour le prix
d'un on ne s'en prive pas
aujourd'hui la troupe de la comédie
musicale la belle et la bête s'est
produite au centre commercial parly 2 au
chesnay lors de ce show case qui a
attiré petits et grands les comédiens
ont interprété les titres phares de leur
spectacle adapté du film de walt disney
ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui se passe dans le théâtre alors
évidemment il n'y a pas de coups suez
après de décor c'est différent on parce
qu'on est habitué à voir
avec les chansons une atmosphère un
décor de ce crime pour chaque personnage
le grès est quelque peu différent après
c'est tout aussi plaisant ah oui ça fait
plaisir car moi je pars pour madame sa
mort parce que toi encore ça peut aller
mais on aime ça me voir elle c'est une
grosse des guerres et elle a le bras
constamment comme ça donc à vivre au
jour le jour c'est facile face au dollar
après c'est vrai que là se troue sur ces
petits salazie mais j'ai l'habitude
comme ça donc ça fait bizarre non non ça
fait plaisir
ça va
allez nous sommes mercredi donc
retrouvons vos sorties ciné au micro d'
elodie moi je pensais que c'était un peu
plus hachée par beaucoup de choses
c'est quand même un film extrêmement
moyens et je suis gentil s'est dit trop
marrant oui j'adore kev adams film très
émouvant
super film très attachant et on s'ennuie
pas une minute et on s'attache à tous
les tous ces élèves et on leur souhaite
une bonne chance j'ai trouvé que c'est
un documentaire vraiment très
intéressant très émouvant et je trouve
que c'est assez encourageant de voir
tous ces jeunes qui font l'effort
d'apprendre le français et je trouve que
c'est un film très optimiste très bon
film manque un peu de rythme je trouve
dans le film mais bon gros casting c'est
bien de voir une partie de la guerre qui
est rarement des pentes au cinéma je
trouve j'ai pensé que c'est plutôt bien
effectivement que cette insulte je sais
aussi un sujet de chez toi intéressant
de s'intéresser à cette partie de la
seconde guerre mondiale qui est souvent
passée sous silence généralement donc
mon bilan serait plutôt positif je pense
sans plus quoi j'ai
c'est très bien mises en scène y de très
grands acteurs mais ça va pas passionner
disons c'est un excellent film au
scénario est bon les acteurs sont bons
c'est très sympa notre professionnels du
cinéma cette semaine c'est lui beaucamp
directeur du ciné s'est taillé l'encours
qui nous livre son coup de coeur dans
les côtes
mon coup de coeur aujourd'hui c'est le
magnifique film diplomatie de volker
schlöndorff excusez moi je vais à
prononcer son nom avec un duo étonnant
qui a déjà d'ailleurs interprété cette
pièce puisque le film est issu d'une
pièce nice arestrup récemment césarisé
et le grand andré dussollier donc c'est
un face à face se passe pendant la
guerre 39 45 et qui va permettre à paris
de conserver ses murs ses immeubles ses
terres et c'est passionnant c'est assez
théâtralise évidemment d'un vraiment eu
huit clos mais c'est un très beau film à
découvrir donc aussi 17 cette semaine
s'il avait rempli les chefs drôme où
néron que l'eau produit la place de la
concorde
et en plus ces enfants de jouer dans les
parcs
les deux tours de notre-dame
toutefois et c'est pareil pour toujours
vous n'avez aucun remords
mais quel homme est fou dans
notre mission est à présent terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv fier je
vous retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
en direct à 18h30 à mercredi